who should we be trusting on these
issues
of public health public health the most
the great the our true government the
public health
who should we be trusting the experts
or people who have a little bit of
common sense
i got in trouble i got in trouble
yesterday you probably saw the episode
it was taken down on youtube the
segments taken down because i
played a clip of joe rogan and joe rogan
in that clip
discouraged young people from getting
the vaccine because he said look you're
quite healthy and so you just some
people
are at a far greater risk from covid and
you're not really at
nearly as great a risk so you know if i
were a young person i wouldn't get it
doc de fauci our great exalted leader
was asked about this joe rogan clip on
the today show he said
absolutely not joe rogan totally wrong
don't listen to him everyone get the
vaccine immediately
young healthy people shouldn't get
vaccinated just quickly your response
well that's incorrect savannah and the
reason why is that you're talking about
yourself in a vacuum then
you're worried about yourself getting
infected in likelihood that you're not
going to get any symptoms
but you can get infected and will get
infected if you put yourself at risk
and even if you don't have any symptoms
you're propagating the outbreak because
it is likely that you
even if you have no symptoms that you
may inadvertently and
innocently then infect someone else who
might infect
someone who really could have a problem
with a severe outcome
so if you want to only worry about
yourself and not society
then that's okay but if you're saying to
yourself even if i get infected
i could do damage to somebody else even
if i have no symptoms at all
and that's the reason why you've got to
be careful and get vaccinated yes
so if if you only care about yourself
you disgusting selfish peasant
then fine maybe don't get the vaccine i
mean i'm still gonna make you
but if you're a good person then you
should get the vaccine
go jump in a lake this guy the vaccine
super duper effective right
vaccines vaccine available basically to
every single person in the country right
now
so other than children because it's not
it's not approved for children yet
even though it's totally it's great it's
awesome there's no question about it
whatsoever
but still not but it's approved for
everybody else other than children
so everyone can get the vaccine just
about
but you still need to get the vaccine
because
otherwise even if you're not at risk
really from the virus
if you you could carry the virus and be
asymptomatic and you could give it to
other people
who are already by the way immune
because the vaccine works totally great
so they don't really need to worry about
getting it but you could have to worry
about giving it to the people who don't
have to worry about getting it is that
is that the argument get the vaccine
sheep
with a mask sheep so i'm i'm not going
to make
any scientific point on on the vaccine
i'm not going to make any scientific
point on the masks i'm not going to make
any scientific argument
on the whole virus because i'm not
allowed to
youtube won't allow me you see the the
liberal establishment acting through
youtube
is so confident of its argument that it
will not permit me to read a
peer-reviewed
scientific study from the national
institutes of health that's how
confident they are
that they are speaking for the science
that's how confident they and their
arguments so i'm not going to do that
if you want to hear me read the
peer-reviewed scientific study about the
masks
contradicting all of the wonderful
proclamations of our public health
overlords go to dailywire.com because
you'll be able to
check it out over there i would strongly
recommend you do that
but i'm not going to do it because you
know if we go on youtube we're not
allowed to say that
i'm just going to make the purely
political
argument
i think the masks are dumb i'm not
saying that from a scientific standpoint
i'm not saying they don't work
not right now i'm not saying that i'm
saying as a political matter
it is disordered this is a disordered
thing for society
to wear the secular kefia over your face
it is a disordered thing for society to
continue to go around
muzzling yourself not seeing people
smile not going out
being able to breathe fresh air and see
the expressions on our faces man is the
political animal
in aristotle's term why because we have
speech because we communicate with one
another because we're social
that is the defining political quality
of man
it's what separates us from the animals
and these idiots
these power mad
idiots are stopping us from doing that
and we are following along hey hold on
if by some strange chance we are still
on youtube right now
i need you to ring the button and smash
the
doodad and hit the gizmo i don't know
man i don't know what you you
say subscribe to this channel so that
you do not miss a single
video because i'll tell you the powers
that be
they don't always love our content okay
so just make sure
you subscribe right now ring that bell
and that way you will get to see
all of these pearls of wisdom coming up
[Music]
[Music]